الى كندا الان وتحديدا لموبايل فعاليات
مؤتمر الامم المتحده كوب 15 للتنوع
البيروجيه متواصله المؤتمر الذي يتواصلتني
لغايه التاسعه عشر من الشهر الحالي يجدو
نفسه امام تحدي انهاء المتمثل في التواصل
الى اتفاق في اقل من اسبوعين لانقاذ
الانواع والبيئه الطبيعيه من ذمار لا عوده
عنه في هذا الشان عاد نمر الاطلس او كما
يطلق عليه ايضا النمر البربري عاده ظهور
اذا بعد عقود من الغياب في منطقه الساوره
جنوب غرب الجزائر
من هناك ينضم الينا الاستاذ رضوان الطاهري
المخرج والمنتج والباحث في التنوع
الحيوانيه استاذ رضوان الطاهري اهلا وسهلا
بك على
نتوقف معك عند هذا الخبر الذي ربما اكدته
نمر الاطلس غابه لعقود لكنه عاد للظهور
وان تكون من اكدت هذا الامر ما قصته كيف
حصل ذلك
هذا ظهورك كان
تتبع طويل سنوات حوالي 10 سنوات
ليومنا هذا وصلت ل 50 مشاهده 50 شهاده
انهم شاهدوا النمر الاطلسي كان هذا مرفق
به وثائقي
تنوع النباتي والحيوان في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ما قال علمي ليتحدث على ظهور النمر ولكن
اخر المقال العلمي حتى يظهر الحلقه
الاخيره لهذا الفيلم اللي ينهار فيها مقطع
صغير من هذا النمر الاطلسي
والصحيحها بعض
الناس كثير يظنون ان النمر الاطلسي هو
الفهد الاطلسي بين النمر الاطلسي والفهد
الاطلسي الفهد متواجد في تمنراس بالجزائر
اقصى الجنوب الجزائر اما النمر الاطلسي
فهو منقرض منذ الاستقلال تقريبا منذ منذ
الخمسينيات يعني حوالي 60 سنه
لتظهر شهادات اخر
الشكوك في 2007 من باحتين اجانب ان احتمال
وجود نمر اطلسي لكن في المنطقه اللي
اتواجد فيها الثوره منطقه شاسعه وكان لها
ان يختبئ في المنطقات كما
صورت في الوثائق بعد الغزلان المعلقه فوق
جذوع الاشجار وهو الوحيد الذي يفعل هذه
الفعل هو الوحيد القادر على حمل الغزال
ووضعه فوق الشجره
رضوان طاهري اساور البريه هو عنوان هذا
الوثائقي الذي قمت بتصويره ويعاكس الحياه
البريه في منطقه الساوره في الجنوب
للجزائر اليوم ما الرساله التي توجهها انت
كونك عاشق الحياه البريه في حين ربما تعقد
في مغير الكنديه هذه القمه قمه الامم
المتحده للتنوع البيولوجيه
الرساله هي دق ناقوس الخطا هو اصلا
الوثائقي عمل على شكل
الحيوانات وبعدها الرساله تكون انقذوا هذه
الحيوانات المتواجده من نهايه الانقراض
لان الصيد الجائر ولان للتطور التكنولوجيا
اصبح يقضي عليها ولا ايش يجعل لها مكان
للعيش هذا النمر الاطلسي كان مختلف في
سلاسل الجبليه منيعه اليوم تطور اصبح
الفتح طرقات الى الجبال وفتح المسالك
الواعره ما ادى بالحيوان
لربما لاختفاء للابد هو كان بصيص امل انه
موجود واليوم انه موجود وسوف يرفق بمقال
علمي الذي سوف
يكشف حقائق جديده لان ال- ال- اثاره
بالعشرات موجوده حتى من طرف من الدول التي
تقع على سبيل المثال عمار محمد هذا ايضا
والثقه اثاره في في جانب من جانب المغرب
اما ابن جانب الجزائر فكان فكانت
المعلومات يعني دقمه بحيث انك موثقه
بالصوت والصوره
من بعض الدلائل الجينيه على وجود هذا
النمر الاطلسي اللي هو مختلف عن النمر
الافريقي
المخرج المنتج والباحث في التنوع الحيواني
على شهادتك شكرا